as european countries seek out new
energy sources some are increasing their
use of nuclear power but
finding locations to store radioactive
waste has been a consistent problem
finland is pioneering a system to
permanently contain all its spent
nuclear material some communities there
are embracing the waste as dw's terry
schultz found out
who wants to live next to a nuclear site
well this guy for one and evidently most
of the other some 9 000 residents of the
town of erioke finland it's the proud
home to three nuclear reactors and
opening soon the world's first permanent
storage site for high-level radioactive
waste
they get their
real estate taxes it's about 20 million
per year aorioki mayor vessel yami says
decades of good relations and no
accidents with the oki luato nuclear
power plant led his community to
actively campaign to be chosen also as
the location for the oncolu repository
the facility is being called a game
changer in the nuclear power industry
because the waste is deposited so deep
in the earth it will never have to be
moved
lakanyemi considers that a win for his
town long-term financial security we
have renovated schools and and we
ancoinsu
a
sports hull here it's cost about 8
million euros the economic boost from
the nuclear industry is welcome but
embracing its waste requires deep trust
and expertise and authority part of the
bedrock of finnish society
thanks to that and the unique
suitability of the actual finnish
bedrock this country is making history
half a kilometer below ground welcome to
hong kong when the site becomes
operational within the next couple of
years
the spent nuclear fuel will be
transferred into steel canisters and
then copper capsules lowered into
tunnels and sealed off forever
at the moment the enclosed site is still
in its trial phase as experts continue
finalizing the details of permanently
disposing of spent nuclear fuel with
such high level radioactive waste
there's no room for missed steps looked
good geologist johanna hansen says every
precaution is being taken to ensure that
also in the far future that there are no
um
any any pathways into the surface so so
this
facility will store
the canisters for hundred thousand of
years
though the project has been underway
underground for almost two decades it's
getting new interest from abroad that's
due in part to the european parliament's
designation of nuclear power as a green
fuel and the push in europe to reduce
dependence on russia as an energy
supplier as it wages war on ukraine so
ankalo is getting lots of attention
these days and not only from scientists
and journalists seventeen thousand
people per year come to see this
interactive visitor center and take a
tour of the facility posse tuahima heads
up communications for pussiva the
company responsible for oncology he says
his goal is to demystify the process of
nuclear power generation a lot of people
say that okay nuclear is good but then
you have this
waste of used nuclear fuel but
what we are saying is that no that's not
true we do have
the solution for that and it's
completely safe tuohima says he expects
more european countries to follow
finland's lead now that they're forced
to reconsider how to power their futures
[Applause]